la politique ce dimanche avec
essentiellement des réactions suscitées
par une petite phrase de nuit hier par
le chef de l'état devant les membres de
l'ump réunis en conseil national à paris
nicolas sarkozy était revenu sur la
france qui changent et les grèves dont
personne ne s'aperçoit une phrase
commenté aujourd'hui j'habite humbert
car marie denis devant les cadres de
l'ump nicolas sarkozy s'est taillé un
beau succès la france est en train de
changer
elle chante beaucoup plus vite et
beaucoup plus profondément qu'on le
croit désormais quand il ya une grève en
france personne ne s'en aperçoit
cette bonne humeur présidentielle
beaucoup en revanche s'en sont aperçus
ils ont plutôt mal prise la fsu le
principal syndicat enseignant parle de
fanfaronnades de tribunes le leader de
force ouvrière n'en pense pas moins
c'est une phrase de trop du président de
la république il est habitué de ce type
de provocation d'abord au moins je
rappellerai que les grèves parfois ça
marche parfois ça ne marche pas c'est
comme les sondages ça y est je connais
des gens qui sont très bas dans les
sondages bien pour eux ça ne marche pas
non plus le président de la république
joue avec le feu considère la cgt même
tonalité du côté politique au ps
ce genre de déclarations nerfs et
agressent ceux qui expriment
désaccord avec eux mais qu'ils expriment
aujourd'hui et mécontentement ou son
temps
il y aura fusion de toutes ses colères
là et ça donnera lieu une explosion mai
dernier argument donné par un ministre
nicolas sarkozy voulait rassurer les
européens la france n'est plus le pays
de la grève
[Musique]